live long like you would big smiles big
heart big service all love officer Sean
Collier we love you the Institute can be
the committee to think about a memorial
for Sean Collier the figure of the
memorial is the kind of five walled
structure is extruded and then a void is
actually carved out of it and that void
represents a kind of absence or a loss
the form itself is based on the hand
representing both a kind of gesture of
openness to others but also the ability
to apply oneself to make things better
we wanted the stone to be representative
of the places where Sean spent a lot of
time with like the MIT community he was
very active at the MIT outing club so
you know we started thinking but like
you know granite New Hampshire the
memorial is made of 32 blocks which
piece together in a way that allows each
block to hold the other one up I'll go
around and get the other two so its
strength comes from unity its strength
comes from the many as opposed to a kind
of singular gesture so here
it's 90 they have and here it's 91 in a
half people don't build anymore this way
so it's an experiment in using really
sort of old-fashioned techniques of
stone masonry sort of pre-modern almost
if you will but using high-end computers
to sort of determine the shape and the
layout of the stones I'm saying what so
we're saying this is a one it's great
it's perfectly
the five walls actually extend out from
the center void and as they extend out
they frame very specific views the two
walls that are closest together align
with the location of Shawn's cruiser
where he was shot it's the most intimate
space in the memorial when you're under
it frames exactly that's not where the
tragedy occurred what we really have are
five half arches which are each leaning
in toward the middle and while that half
arch should fall over there's another
half arch somewhere else leaning in and
another half arch and another half arch
so each of these are coming together and
balancing perfectly in the middle so the
arch is exerting an outward force in the
walls the five radiating walls are
buttressing the central part of a very
flat vault as those arches push outward
on the walls the walls want to spread
apart and so buried underground there's
a tension tie which is pulling back
toward the center and which is pulling
the whole memorial together so it's an
equilibrium
below ground there's a great beam which
is poured in concrete and it's
reinforced concrete so they're steel
embedded within the concrete which
carries the tensile forces to ensure
that the walls will not move outward
over the centuries the outside of this
sculpture is all going to be a flamed
finish this is a very fine grain very
dense granite and leaves still a fairly
flat but a more natural textured surface
each stone is cut with advanced milling
technology some of the stones are cut by
robots and the accuracy of each stone is
within about one millimeter even as the
robot is carving the blocks someone has
to come in and tap every single piece
and break it off kind of one by one
before then the robot can come in for
its final pass it was a kind of
incredible dance between like machine
and man to carve these pieces
it's like a three-dimensional jigsaw
puzzle with finely polished blocks of
granite but in this case they weigh
about 10,000 pounds each
name's Rob Rogers I'm a project manager
with Suffolk construction I'm also a
Sean Colliers brother there's a sequence
and how we're gonna lower the stones so
in theory the stone should walk in place
when the first blocks arrive and start
to take physical form as an architect
that's a magical moment when concept
turns into physical reality
there were many times in this whole
project where you know we had to keep
our emotions in check because it was
such an emotional project for for
everyone involved
it's been a very humbling and healing
passed almost two years since Shaw was
gone so it's really helped a lot
we started with the Keystone and we had
to build a temporary scaffold under that
Keystone then the ring stones that
surround the Keystone came in next and
we sequentially went through each of the
five legs as has probably been the
hardest season to build in well we have
a hundred nine inches worst winter ever
in Boston it made things more
challenging but everyone on site was
great I mean we kind of knew they we
have an end date we need to meet this
date so guys worked hard they worked
longer the most exciting moment and the
most critical moment in the construction
is when we lower the scaffolding in the
weight of the great Keystone and the
flat vault goes into the five walls
really for the first time
okay we've got it instrumented for
displacements in 25 different locations
and then we've got nine scales
underneath the taking load readings so
we're going to be doing real-time
measurements of how the load is being
transferred so we're going to go ahead
and start with the four middle ones as
we lower the temporary supports and they
come down the load on the scales should
come down and the load on the scales
will be going down because the weight of
the stones will be going into arching if
we lower the supports and the reading on
the scale doesn't change that's bad
so behind B leg is a little part of my
speech that I gave for Sean so they
engraved it onto the stone so live long
like he would big hearts big smiles big
service all love he was just a kid that
just loved being a cop you know he had a
million friends I don't know how he
slept he was always doing something
hanging out with somebody you know you
really lived life so his you know
fullest
he was made to be a police officer I
know his mother said he wanted to be a
policeman from the time he was seven
years old in a joke it showed in
everything he did he got it
they're very open structure for
something built out of such solid stone
and it's sort of supposed to be a
gateway into campus you know there's
people milling around they spend a lot
of time in Northport they like to be
outside and so you know we have these
benches and I think there will be trees
and it will hopefully become a place
that people really enjoy sitting down
and spending some time with their
friends and the community
I hope the memorial will become one of
the beloved elements on campus hopefully
it can remain for us to remember strong
service and the coming together of the
community and our values they're gonna
be much better